[Applause]
[Music]
i present to you
the rational consumer
as it were
i don't like your tone look they were
sold out of all the other costumes
okay i think we all live in the real
world here
let's not pretend to be unaware of what
sells in this office
hey remember my boyfriend derek
and his boyfriend ben yeah hi
it's totally okay that you didn't wear a
costume
i did i'm a straight person hey
sorry i'm late see
oh check this out my key to the city of
gary indiana
um look at this and my gold record from
that novelty party song
spooky scary boys becoming men
then becoming wool get this i just asked
the dj what rem albums he has
he's got monster but not automatic for
the people
wow i know it's like what is this a mid
90s party no it's an
early 90s party okay larry tell us how
this looks ben wants to do a
synchronized couple skate to losing my
religion
hit it
leslie leslie leslie i'm sorry but we
have a problem
his name is jeremy jam well as noted in
article nine
well whoa jam i thought this bill was
tabled yes
and i called a special session and
untabled it what is up with
the roller skates i was about to attend
a roller skating birthday party for my
husband but this is more important yeah
i don't care i'm a blades guy
point of order the councilwoman wishes
to speak on this
will the councilwoman yield her time so
we can vote on this sucker no
i will not yield nor will i yield for
the rest of the evening
a filibuster are you duking on my chest
right now
no gross and yes it's a filibuster okay
i am not willing to let you deprive me
she is filibustering on roller skates
she's gonna be strapped into those
things for hours i know this is a dire
situation but i swear to god this is
like a crazy
sex fantasy for me
now you're all gonna need aliases cool
i'm gonna be
diana tremaine that was the name of my
fake id in high school
her address was one two three whatever
street canada city
canada arizona bouncers are the best
character work
such fun i actually dabbled in a bit of
acting after university
although mostly i just stood around
while baslerman just threw glitter on me
oh i shall be rhonda mumps and i work
down at the hot dog factory
you need to be more specific there are
nine hot dog torture departments
making people into stuffing people with
oh stuffing people sounds fun
is that like shoving them into the
throats of vegans yes
throats i know what my secret identity
is you cannot be blake bortles fine
then i'll be jake don't say jordals
jordals
and i work in the molotov cocktail
department gotta get in on this
hey it's cool man i work in the
warehouse i'm cool
i'm hip and i'm jive but i don't care
about
nobody do you know who i am happy
halloween
jerk still don't know who i am i'll give
you a hint
i go over other people's heads michael
this is a bad idea
what's a bad idea dressing up as
somebody i mean when has that ever
worked for you
never okay you know what fine
i'm not daryl and thank god i'm not
daryl could you for once just let us
enjoy a party instead of making it about
all your issues
i don't ask for much for christmas i
really don't
it's not like i am begging people to buy
me
diamonds and broach
pendants oh buy me something expensive
or i'm going to kill myself that's not
i don't care about that all i want to be
is santa
and you want to take that away from me
fine go ahead but when you need my help
because i am ruining everything don't
look at me
that's great behold
jesus christ and i bring to you
glad christmas tidings i want to remind
everyone
the true meaning of christmas those of
you who wish to join me
that's great i am excited by that and
those of you who don't
i forgive you but i never forget wow
michael
this must be obvious how wrong this is
oh
the antichrist this just derived from
the dunder mifflin north pole branch
we don't have a north pole branch idiot
oh oh what's dwight gonna get what is
it yes oh
yes it's space garbage dwight's gonna be
able to build himself a friend
calls with crap
you've been very good this year i have
yeah except for cheating on your wife
adultery is a sin look it up in the
bible people what'd he get
he got scented candles oh well that's
appropriate
a lot of fire where you're going better
get used to it
you're going to h-e-l-l-double hockey
sticks going to hell stanley
amen and this brings us to you little
one
i can't see from here people somebody
shout it out don't make me get up
it's fabric i really wanted this
that's fantastic you can make another
dress that goes past your feet
and you just forgot to mention this
hidden compartment
that is a phoenix feather sir not a
weapon if you're familiar with the most
popular franchise in the history of film
maybe you wouldn't experience such
confusion here my apologies is this my
normally insane buddy is a little on
edge because of the very tight window
that exists between
our arrival at heathrow and the rupert
grint meet and greet at leicester square
i am a great grunt loud and proud wait
wait wait diaz looks like a dirty
criminal
but you look like a cop man you can't go
over there like that what do you have in
mind
don't call it a comeback i've been here
boom explosion
i don't look like a cop now no you look
like a boyz man easter album
i'm like that cool witty girl who kind
of like kills it in bed you know
i need a funny costume say no more i
will go to the store and return with a
costume that is the pinnacle of wit
[Music]
i am not going on my halloween date as a
urinal come on it's funny
it's edgy it's topical no you sure
oh okay well i anticipated this so uh
i got some other options betsy a condom
a butt
a tampon ace ventura
sperm all terrible spirits you are
terrible all right a woman
should not have to choose between being
hot and funny for halloween
so thank you for your help i'm okay i'm
just gonna create a costume that is both
hilarious
and sexy tinkerbell taylor soldier spy
dirty harry potter
little wayne in the prairie
hey ann ann called she wants her ugly
outfit back
why are you dressed as a pilgrim leslie
said it was a come as you were in the
90s party i assumed it was the 1690s
babe if it was the 1690s we'd all be
mummies what do you think mummies are
skeletons oh boy it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume i was going to sir but then i
decided
screw that jazz well i'm the only one
who ever dresses up
no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so i'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts yes
charles seriously no costume
what the hell charles where's your
halloween spirit but
you guys always make fun of me i have
never once
insulted you in my life especially
vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume
does it matter if i say no no
[Music]
bam bam boom
what's the what why are you dressed up
you look like an idiot but uh but
yeah what are you supposed to be a sassy
car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart
i am not you know who i am squad that's
enough
you're making boyle for bad on purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoical the
canadian figures game
you